Crazy about your crush?
Chances are, they might also be into you.
Here are seven sure signs your crush likes
you back.
One; they make time to see you.
Some people are naturally fast and known to
do the queen bees and kings of texting, but
if your crash is especially shy and reserved
and know to be unresponsive but makes time
to see you, this is a dead giveaway that they
enjoy your company.
Two: they make excuses to get close to you.
Do they ever brush their arm against yours
or give you hugs?
Physical affection is sweet and they might
be trying to show you that they...
You know, like - like you.
Three; they remember the small details about
you.
If they seem to know you more than you know
yourself, not only do they like you back but
you've also found yourself a keeper.
Four; they let you in on their personal life.
How close is too close until it's time to
make a move?
When someone is being real with you, they
let you in on their secrets.
That includes embarrassing stories, thinks
they aren't so proud of or memories that still
haunt them.
Congratulations!
This means they feel at ease with you.
Five; they develop an interest in your hobbies.
Maybe you love playing League of Legends or
enjoy baking.
If your crush who's usually not into those
activities starts to play video games with
you or bakes you cookies, they might be trying
to impress you.
Six; they act cold and distant randomly.
Okay, this sounds weird right?
But sometimes people, especially shy ones,
try to seem like they don't like you, fearing
you don't reciprocate the same feelings.
It's the whole fight-or-flight scenario.
Deep down though, they hope you notice their
absence and want you to reach out.
Seven; they make it obvious that they're single.
Thinks it's too good to be true?
Think again.
If they haven't friend-zoned you by calling
you their sis or bro, then this is a sure
sign.
They've already made up their mind about their
feelings but do they know you have?
Be bold and make the next move, you never
really know unless you try.
Do any of these signs sound familiar?
What's stopping you from asking your crush
out?
Please share your thoughts with us below.
Also be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more helpful tips and share this video with
others.
With your help, we can reach more people and
provide our supports.
Thanks for watching!
Hi everyone.
As you may have noticed, we don't post as
often as we'd like anymore.
We are low on funding as our expenses are
exceeding our revenue.
However, we want to keep making more content
that help people learn about psychology and
mental health.
So we want you to be a part of that process.
Starting today, we will have a donate button
underneath our videos.
You've probably seen it in some of your favorite
channels already but if you don't see the
button, we've included a link in the video
description.
Our vision is to keep making psychology more
accessible to everyone.
We try to keep our videos concise and create
open dialogues among the community.
As a supporter, you will receive recognition
for your support by having a cool site icon
next to your username when you comment.
This helps us recognize it's you and engage
you more.
On top of this, you will also receive a free
copy of our Psych2Go eBook and occasional
magazines every quarter.
Just email in to myself when you've donated
and I will send you the copies at tai@psych2go.net.
However, even if you cannot support us financially,
we still totally understand.
You can help us out by sharing this video.
We still love you and we'll give you a free
eBook if you mail in to let us know.
There is no fixed term or shady things like
that.
You can also cancel your support at any time
too.
So there's absolutely no risk.
We promise to use your funding wisely and
for creating new videos that can help others.
Let's make psychology more accessible for
everyone.